you sell a script you then start from
one again yeah how is that so is it like
you're beating a drum and you're the
only
drummer in the band and then it's up to
you
it's it's the treadmill um and this is
like the
i have novels friends of mine and they
they say that basically writing novels
now is a treadmill because
you need a new novel to sell the old
novels uh and once the book's been on
the shelf for a while
everyone that's gonna read it has read
it so you now need to have a new
book that people can read which means
it's always a treadmill same thing with
screenwriting is
once you write a script and you sell it
and do the rewrites on that
you now have to sell another script or
at least have a script that goes out
wide enough so that people become
interested in you
and say we want to bring that guy in for
meetings because we have some
project that we think they'd be good at
you know it's they they've bought the
right to scrabble and they want to make
it into a movie
and they're they're interviewing
screenwriters and you need to have a new
script to get that interview
and so you're constantly writing new
material there's there's not a day off
in a screenwriter's life you know you're
once you write a script and you finish
it you better think about what the next
script is going to be
and part of that is you have to
you know when i talk about the hundred
ideas you have to always have new ideas
that you can put into a script so that
you keep writing
there will be times in your career where
you have that script that's
that goes wide and gets you enough
meetings that and this is
you know pretty much a career thing
enough meetings that now you set up
other projects
based on that one script that went out
so you take scrabble the movie
somebody offers that to you take that
job somebody else
offers you some other project um
i had a a meeting once where they gave
me this
overly xerox xerox of xerox of a
magazine article that literally had
inky fingerprints all over it so i knew
that every writer in hollywood had read
it but me
they gave it to me and said we want you
to read this and come back and pitch a
story idea to us
and i read it and it was like the most
boring
true life story ever and i sort of went
there's no
way to make this into a movie and they
said that's what everybody else said but
we think
you can do it and so you end up with
things like that
they give you novels to read i said
uh once before that i famously turned
down angels and demons when they offered
it to me
because i read the book and i did not
like the book and the book has
two stories that meet at the end that
doesn't work in movies and so i told the
producer that i would only want to do
one of the stories and he goes no it's
got to be both stories
so i said nah i'm not going to do it and
turn down angels and demons and it's
like
but you can go once the script goes wide
you end up with a bunch of meetings and
everyone wants you to do some project
and you can literally like first of all
get a pile of free paperback books or
hardback books sometimes
and then have to read them all and come
back and pitch your take to all these
different companies
and if you don't have the take they want
you've just done all that for nothing
and you know you eventually somebody has
to say yes
or else you're doing a lot of work for
no money